[Music]
welcome to our session covering the
google cloud security engineer training
and professional google cloud security
engineer certification
we have some great opportunities to
share with you and your teams
i'm mara sauce the google cloud
credentials engagement lead
now the market demand for security
engineers is undeniable
our partners and customers are looking
for individuals with the validated
certified skills to help with their
toughest security challenges
recently collected data illustrates that
83
of google cloud certified professionals
feel their resume is more attractive
after a certification
the same report states that 87 of google
cloud certified individuals are more
confident about their cloud skills
and finally the report found that 71
of google cloud certified individuals
report that becoming certified enabled
or will enable their employer to get
more business increase work with
existing customers or help scale up
their business
these valuable insights speak to the
opportunity that investing in google
cloud training and certification can
bring to both your career and your
organization
so to talk more about this opportunity i
welcome aaron
i'm aaron sutton a strategic cloud
engineer with google cloud professional
services focusing on security as a cloud
engineer i've had the opportunity to
work with numerous customers over the
last few years
one common request among customers
regardless of their size or industry is
to understand common security best
practices and architectures
security professional certification not
only provides cloud and security
practitioners with knowledge of the
unique features of gcp security products
but also goes into great detail
regarding common industry security
practices
the knowledge gained from this exam
has enabled me to help customers quickly
deploy their workloads on gcp in a more
safe and secure manner
more recently i've been working with
some of our large enterprise customers
in regulated industries
with these customers i've learned that
virtually every conversation is a
security conversation
when designing a foundational deployment
infrastructure as code pipeline or data
warehouse solution security can't simply
be added on at the end
security needs to be front and center in
the design satisfying the strict and
exhaustive requirements of these
customers often involves interacting
with numerous security teams
each with their own area of concern and
specific needs and controls
designing solutions for these teams that
stitch together the various requirements
in a logical and coherent manner is a
non-trivial exercise that requires
knowledge across multiple facets of
cyber security security professional
engineer certification provides you more
than just a service level understanding
of these subjects it goes into great
depth regarding gcp products
capabilities and industry best practices
which will allow you to speak to the
needs of the various security teams
it provides the building blocks to
design security architectures that
address common concerns and the unique
requirements of a particular customer or
stakeholder
i really think that the professional
google cloud security engineer
certification can benefit anyone working
in cloud even if you're not a security
practitioner whether you have 20
developers or 20 000 developers the
security posture of your environment is
of paramount importance
having employees with security knowledge
adds another layer of defense when it
comes to helping you protect your
critical data and workloads
the security professional certification
has been an indispensable tool for me
when it comes to designing better
solutions for our customers
gain expertise and supercharge your
security career with the professional
google cloud security engineer
certification
start preparing today with 30 days of
free hands-on training available to you
on our on-demand learning platform
google cloud skills boost
best of luck on your training and
certification journey